China's government has made a radical
shift this morning officially moving
away from its strict zero covet policies
now this move appears to be in response
to widespread protests in recent weeks
including some of the boldest
demonstrations this country has seen in
decades Elizabeth Palmer is following
this story
China's national Health commission held
a press conference
to announce that mandatory coveted
testing for most people will end
immediately they'll no longer have to
show a negative test result in public
places and those armies of health
workers and hazmat suits will stop
locking down apartment complexes also
people with covid won't be forced into
State quarantine they'll be able to
recover at home all that and a
commitment to vaccinating the elderly
sounds like common sense but it's a huge
climb down for Xi Jinping and the
Communist Party
[Music]
who watched protests erupt in over 20
cities with calls for Freedom not
lockdowns
today the protesters got a lot of what
they wanted but because the government
has convinced people that covet is
dangerously lethal the new rules have
brought fresh anxiety at the shicha Hai
River where Hardy beijingers head to
swim this regular was getting ready to
plunge in
I'm confused is zero coveted better or
or should we learn to live with the
virus this government flip-flop I'm just
not sure which side to pick he's already
picked not getting a vaccine he's chosen
to ward off covid with a freezing dip to
boost his immune system
the risk now is with so many
under-vaccinated elderly people China is
facing a huge surge in coveted deaths
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Tokyo